I see populism as people rising up to
reject their leadership now it's a bad
thing yes that that they're not willing
to accept the results I agree with your
definition I agree with your definition
and then also at the same time that
that's happening they'll win at all cost
they'll they won't compromise they will
win they will fight for that side and
win okay fair enough and that's not good
but I mean I guess my question is why
don't you have more criticism for our
Elites who are running all these
institutions are making these decisions
I do I I mean it depends what
you're I I I I I wrote a piece about
four four years ago which says why and
how capitalism needs to be
reformed and I believe that on these
issues of equal opportunity and all that
we've got a big structural problem and
that um everything needs to be reformed
I'm not against capitalism but it needs
to be reformed and part of the big
problem just analytically mechanic Ally
is that um it's it's the profit system
alone does not direct resources
adequately let's say if we take climate
for example um there was costs terrible
costs that come from climate it's not
built into the system education look at
the gaps in education this the
structural system means that the central
government can uh that state government
controls education then you get to the
town and at the Town level it's the town
that controls the education how much
they pay and so then you create wealth
gaps with rich people being able to take
care of their kids in a way that other
people can't take care of their kids and
that creates an opportunity Gap that's a
structural problem it has to be taken on
full looked at reformed and we in order
to pull this thing off we have to do it
together okay we cannot do it with one
side fighting the other side and with
irreconcilable differences